[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
w
la
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to Gamespot we
are here with the GDC 2017 Indie mix
live stream we are showing off six indie
games that we have into the studio today
I'm here with Paulo Rook from sector K
games hey thanks for having us Mike I'm
really glad everybody's coming in you
are the sound designer and composer here
on punch Planet which we'll show in a
second yep uh yeah so people joining us
we're just going to be every uh you know
20 minutes we're going to be swapping
out developers just showing off the
games uh we have a lot of developers in
town in San Francisco this week for GDC
and we would be remiss if we did not
show off some of the great games they're
bringing to the table and uh yeah I
guess we'll justum jum right in uh aw so
Paul tell me about punch Planet punch
planet is very much a competitive
fighting game we are all three of us
competitive fighting game players so
it's uh Pretty Natural for us to want to
make if we're going to make a game it's
going to be a fighting game so this is
like a 2d sci-fi uh fighting game based
in like a lot of the old ' 80s and 90s
sci-fi films we're all such fans of uh
it's 3D you know models but played in
two and 2 and a half D I guess they call
it yeah yeah 2D fighting
plane boxes got two other guys from
sector K games here playing uh I'm not
good at fighting games so that is a
Advantage for everybody
watching so uh what's uh you said these
are the two characters royan Sid what
what kind of inspiration went into
making this and or I mean it's going
into making this yeah I think we know we
we all grew up loving you know all the
big sci-fi and action films coming out
in like the '90s and the ' 80s late '
80s so we a lot of those characters are
really influenced for these guys and you
know Roy is kind of like our undercover
cop who's been framed and he's the main
protagonist for the game for the story
mode um um Sid as a bounty hunter EX
military and everyone kind of has these
like you know semi- trophy backgrounds
that you would kind of hear from your
traditional action films and stuff you
know we just kind of want to fill those
archetypes from our favor stuff okay
cool guys like a Die Hard character kind
of yeah you know whatever if it invokes
that feeling then we're doing it
right so yeah you said you like uh you
guys are like big on the EVO scene and
everything yeah we're um we're a big fan
of like the traditional fighter six
buttons you know you got three punch
buttons with different strengths three
kick buttons and different strengths um
yeah there's a pretty pretty slow game
Flow there's not like air dashing and
like Marvel versus Capcom or anything so
it's a little slower as far as the the
gameplay goes methodical kind of
measured yeah and I think we like we
wanted to go a little crazier with some
of the mechanics so we um we've added a
system called the time cancel and that's
represented by that blue bar there okay
and that uh just fills up slowly as you
play um you can also fill it up if you
successfully land a parry and that's one
of the big mechanics we've added to this
game is everyone has a universal pairing
mechanic okay and you can perform that
by hitting both of the medium buttons
and forward so you can see it that's how
it looks like for a whiff but if someone
tries to you know hit you you can Parry
uh get a big punish off with it nice so
it allows everybody to have kind of like
a good defensive option uh the other way
you can utilize that meter is we have a
jump time cancel so if you dash and you
hit the DTC uh buttons with the four
mediums uh you'll get a little hop which
can kind of set you up for some quick
overhead attacks or some sneaky cross up
attacks um and the last usage which is
probably the more common usage is called
the double time cancel and this can be
performed by pushing the same strength
button you used initially so if you did
a fireball with um light punch you'd hit
it again and you can see he cancels the
recovery needs a lot to extend his combo
some more okay and this is just a meter
you build for free and you just get to
use and then we're using traditional um
meter or two meters will let you do a
super combo uh or you can use one meter
to do an enhan version of your move
awesome and uh what platforms are you
planning this for release on uh right
now it's currently only on Steam okay uh
we'd love to do console stuff but it's
just not in the cards right now for for
development it's just a three-man team
so we're just trying to get it really
solid on Steam cool uh we passed the
green light and everything so now it's
just kind of we really just want to make
sure we give people all the content they
deserve for monly Access title before we
get to that point sure awesome so yeah
like you have uh public plans for like
how many characters you'll include and
like what the story mode will be like I
mean remember you're saying Roy is going
to be the main character of it but uh
what are kind of details can you share
publicly yeah I mean um we haven't
actually implemented anything for story
mode yet but we've planned out quite a
bit of it so you know we haven't really
seen story mode done very great in
fighting games overall and we've look
that's one of the things we'd like to
improve on awesome uh our goal for Early
Access is to have four characters in
online that would be like the bare
minimum for what we think people deserve
to have fun and pay uh for and then uh
but launch would be 1.0 would be eight
characters a full story mode and uh all
features you would expect from a modern
fighting game cool so what kind of
action movie tropes were we going for
with Sid here um you know we just like
the strong women roles in films you know
and uh GI Jane type yeah exactly you
know someone that's just like take no
Guff yeah she's uh she runs her own
mercenary ship and she's you know she's
a a bounty hunter and she's just kind of
roaming the roaming the system sweet
beating people up and getting paid
basically St Roy yeah so what uh this is
three people are working on everything
we're watching now right what's that
like with such a small team because this
is like a side project right kind of I
mean it does not appear to be just a
side project it looks like a you know
full-fledged full-time thing but what's
it like cuz you're at Double find most
of the time right yeah so for Will has
been working on the the fighting game
part of this engine it's made in unity
but he made the logic for the fighting
game part of it uh for the last two and
a half three years uh and then once that
had all been kind of worked out he met
Lee online and Lee is an artist uh out
of New York and he's been hasn't done a
lot in games yet but he has immense
experience in pretty much all the
technical domains for art so he was able
to really fill in like all the the roles
you'd expect from the art Department you
know Direction and uh rigging animating
lighting like a lot of really important
stuff that uh you need a lot of people
for he's just been like our Superman uh
doing that stuff for yeah I really like
it like you mentioned it's like a 2.5d
kind of uh yeah you know like a
perspective but it's also kind of like a
cartoony look to it I like it super you
know like different uh Dr position
against the stabbing and punching
happening I don't want to butcher the
hard work that Lee put into it and under
sell what he did to make it look like
this but I think the end result is that
it's a nice it's not you know Sprite
looking like a Sprite based game but
it's definitely got a nice flat feel
like you you expect from a two
dimensional game
um what was I going to say about that
sorry oh no worries um oh yeah and then
uh they've been working together for
about 10 months on this okay and then I
met uh will at a tournament for Street
Fighter 5 stuff uh in other fighting
games and uh we hit it up hit it off
they had one sound they were using for
everything in the game yeah and then
some temp music so I was like You guys
probably could use some some help with
this and I'm not going to charge you cuz
this is my dream to like work on a
fighting game well I already had my
first Dream which is to make cool stuff
for Tim schaer but then then now I'm
just like living the life getting to
work on a fighting game on the side so
I'm pretty happy definitely well yeah I
mean like fighting games are so nuanced
I mean I I appreciate them I'm not good
at them but I imagine just like
balancing everything out I mean like on
the yeah on like Will's end must have
been tough yeah there's a lot of stuff
that goes into making these and um
making sure that your editor can support
the amount of dynamic changes that go on
with like balance uh I haven't actually
my first time work watching will work
was this weekend this is our first time
all getting together in the same space
you know and and watching him work and
how fast he can just like in editor
while we're running the game just make
small balance tweaks and hit box
adjustments and things like that it just
allows us to really uh tune it live and
and just I don't know it's we iterated
like so many things in just two days
it's like a whole different game so like
what is so like the Parry system seems
pretty big like if if you were to
describe this to like a Die Hard
fighting game fan uh I know like Richard
Lee here Joey and Eric tail yeah
Gamespot just get super into fighting
games what would it be like what are the
defining factors about the systems that
work in this game I think yeah well
we're since we played competitively we
wanted to make the game that we would
like to play you know so we with the
things that we enjoy from Fighters um
which is you know a large skill ceiling
but also um we recognize that there's
there's a really big challenge with
Fighters where when you try to get
someone to play it's kind of hard to get
into and it's always that one V one
personal Journey thing so getting
friends to play with you can be kind of
difficult but I think with um punch
Planet the the mechanics uh like Parry
and things like that are really really
simple I'm like giving people obvious
answers on how to deal with things
usually when I'm showing people the game
and they get frustrated by something I
just say are you parrying and they're
like oh yeah and then they just remember
that they have a complete answer to that
problem so I think a lot of the ways to
solve things are really intuitive in
punch Planet so even if you're not super
good at it if you take a second and just
think about some of the mechanics I
think you'll arrive at the answer to
some of these Solutions a lot easier
than other fighting games right I like
that the parries are kind of based on
that meter it's almost like a resource
management thing cuz like you can waste
them right if you don't use them at the
right time right so the the blue part
the DTC meter is uh or the TC meter is
great because you can just um you don't
have to really worry usually you have a
little bit cuz it's just building all
the time sure and you can build a little
extra if you successfully Parry as well
um but yeah that one's kind of nice cuz
you just you just want to use it it
doesn't it resets every round so you
don't need to to worry about SA it for
something later uh and then the yeah the
yellow meter the ex meter is true
traditional build it by whiffing normals
and doing moves and stuff and taking
damage and that yeah is a little more
precious okay so like you kind of set up
the premise but can you talk any more
about where you want to go with the
story of this game or who's writing it
uh lee is doing all the story Direction
with this game um yeah so uh it's
centered around Roy who's been framed uh
he's an undercover cop so he's kind of
on the run now and um you know the goal
is to introduce the characters in a way
that makes sense in the story and I
don't all of that hasn't 100% been ma
out yet it's still a little bit in flex
but the outline has been sort of drafted
but we're not super ready to talk about
the entire story yet but I think if you
if you like traditional you know action
films from the '90s you get to picture
that kind of Arc a bit that fun ride
with a good action and your highs and
your
lows one thing we wanted to really do
with the story mode as well is teach the
mechanics of the game a bit it's not
just going to be like story cut scenes
and then arcade mode we want to have
custom stuff that really teaches you how
to block high low mixups and how to
Parry certain setups and that's the only
way you can beat this thing is if you
know this mechanic so hopefully by the
time you finish the story mode you feel
a little stronger in the versus aspect
as well
cool yeah it's I mean even obviously
like the people playing right now uh Lee
and Will are pretty well versed in the
game but I mean it does look like it's
again it's pretty impressive that three
people made like what what appears to be
a Nuance game um we can go over their
kits a little bit too since there's
characters yeah there's so this is Sid
um which one is Sid
uh she has you know shitty joke for the
second they the the game uses
traditional um inputs for your special
moves you know quarter circles and
charges motions um uh six Spud normal so
uh Sid has a grenade she can put out uh
which is done with cor Circle forward
kick uh yeah they'll cancel each other
out but they're kind of nice you can use
them um on people's wake up and do kind
of you know tricky setup since the
grenade is going to cover you a bit sure
um she most of her fighting style is
revolves around this combat knife which
has a bit of an electricity stun to it
um so she can do um a knife Rush ability
with core cirle four punch which has
three different strengths uh it kind of
looks like that okay um and then she has
a overhead uh kick called The Knife
wheel and that hits high and if you
counter hit you can combo out of it and
it's pretty fun what kind of uh Parry is
she working with uh she has they all
work with they all have the same um par
mechanic but uh she gets some pretty
safe uh pressure so she's a little she's
a little safer from Perry since she can
kind of do a lot from her Jabs with her
knife cool um doesn't Telegraph as much
yeah exactly her other mechanic that's
pretty cool is any normal that uses a
knife can be charged okay and that has
different properties usually it's more
hit stun but in the case of her St
medium punch it'll be an overhead at
that point uh or you'll get a launcher
from the charge version uh and you can
Dash cancel all those while you're
charging so you can kind of set up that
tricky oh I'm going to overhead you and
then Dash in go for a throw or something
gotcha and then uh did you want us want
to take a look at uh Roy yeah sure we
got like 5 minutes left we can check out
so the two characters implemented right
now Roy and Sid looks like you have
another two under there on the select
screen but looks like it'll be like a
eight total yeah dog is our next uh
project after GDC we're going to get
cranking on getting that character into
the game awesome um and yeah I think
we're been pretty happy with the
pipeline for getting characters in but
with three people only it's kind of you
really have our attention on the right
things not to mention balancing and
everything
right yeah Roy is kind of our I don't
want to you know call him like our
generic character but he's our like
centering everything around Roy he's
kind of like we want him to feel like
the Baseline for the game and if he's
feeling good then we want people to feel
as good as he does right uh so he's got
your traditional zoning archetype um he
has three different directions he can
shoot the gun uh the the low one will
hit low and it lets you also um OTG
which is when the character's already
knocked down you can hit them off the
ground and continue the combo sure um he
has a shoulder
tackle uh which is kind of your just
damager finisher yeah usually if you
know if you've seen the the hit confirm
and that's your kind of like little
finish into that uh two super
abilities uh he has a laser super and he
has a uh punch super is his is his block
just like to kind of tense up his arm
yeah just absorb all the damage on his
elbow yeah and we're still working on um
you know VFX and things like that so we
might end up finding something more
thematic for this but right now yeah
he's just he's just flexing on him and
that's all he needs he can block lasers
no
problem yeah he and we you know we using
traditional things like Target combos as
well so Roy has a couple and in Stand
medium punch stand heavy punch and he
has the stand medium punch stand heavy
kick okay um but yeah he's pretty basic
it makes it a little easier to balance
around them but he also has you know fun
flashy Combos and big damage cool
decision one there we
go yeah it's like a I'm I'm getting a
lot of John mlan vibes from him
yeah's a bad thing my friend voiced him
and you know we gave him the RAS raspy
voice voice
Direction and uh our friend um elth
who's a she's a fun twitch streamer just
check her out she did the voice for uh
Sid
okaya yeah you guys will be over on the
show floor all week for GC yep uh we'll
be at the mix tonight from uh 7 to 11
which is press only but um hopefully
there'll be some cool coverage that
comes out of that awesome Yep and we'll
be uh we'll just be around the week so
if you uh give us yeah definitely if you
find find us come play our game yeah
definitely glad to have you guys in and
everything yeah thanks so much for
having this on yeah
absolutely yeah for those joining we are
doing our gam spot Indie mix for GDC
2017 uh we're going to be wrapping up
punch plan in a few minutes we' got a
couple more if you guys want to do
another round or two yeah these guys
they're not we we do have two guys from
sector K Le will back behind the scenes
playing thank God because I not get
fighting games Paul you would probably
KCK my ass I would not be able to talk
if I was playing this game just get you
into it yeah I I can't talk and play
most games let alone games I'm terrible
at mhm yeah for all intense purposes
this looks this looks fun I want to play
more of this yeah I mean whoever's
winning the most they they don't have to
like they people have to get the coffee
for them and stuff like that right now
so of the three guys on sector K of the
three guys in sector K games who uh who
wins the most is I'm the best yeah for
sure yeah Will's the best because will
gets to work on it every day for a
living but um but then yeah I'm the best
spiritually you kind you kind of have
the power to say that cuz you're the
only one with a microphone on right now
yeah well now that we're yeah exactly
there's no one can contest that on the
best uh unless they scream yeah if I
lose I just tell wild and Nerf things
you know until I can feed him again just
blame it on his design Nerf your
characters cont cool awesome so yeah
we'll probably swap out and do one more
round see who wins do a winner takes off
between Lee and Will over here I wish I
could do a good live commentary be like
he is pushing buttons he is blocking
those buttons yeah I could not cast if
my life depended on it yeah you can just
see this is sort of how the normal game
FL would be it's very much your your
traditional fighting game everyone has
the tools to stop these jumpins and
punish these whip normals and punish
these block
sweeps this will be punch PL you said
right now is confirmed for steam it's
green lit um you don't have a like a
release window I think end end of year
is when we want to be on Early Access so
that's when I think we're we're
comfortable saying that's when we'd like
to be on Steam Early Access
Co so there we go who wait who was that
who won uh Le won all right all right
there we go all right thanks so much for
coming on Paul and yeah Le and will
everybody at sector K games thanks for
showing off punch Planet uh that will be
a steam game like aiming for later in
the year but uh again if you happen to
be in town for GDC go check it out the
Indie mix tonight uh it'll be over on
the show floor the rest of the week the
Indie show Indie Indie mix section uh
yeah thanks so much we appreciate you
coming on Paul thank you so much Mike
thanks so much for showing us punch
Planet uh yeah we'll be rotating people
in and out um we're GNA have uh Joan
from Thunder Lotus games come on right
now actually awesome yeah cool thanks
Paul thanks a
lot uh yeah people just joining uh we
have the YouTube chat and the twitch
chat up and running so if you have uh
any questions to throw me then uh let me
know Joannie we'll have you come on down
uh I think your mic is uh mic is on
we're going to show off we're setting up
sundered uh so this is from Thunder
Lotus games but Joanie so nice to have
you on thank you cool where do you come
from I come from Montreal Canada oh cool
all the way from the East Coast gotcha
yeah I'm I'm in very late last night
yeah I can imagine I'm a former New
Yorker oh nice I like Montreal a lot
it's probably cold there right now very
cold no it's actually warmer because of
uh climate change yeah definitely all
right um cool so we are going to load up
sunnd but uh so you're from Thunder
Lotus games uh can you tell me a bit
about sard what we're about to see for
the next 20 minutes yeah it's uh sard is
a it's a basically a horrifying fight
for survival and Sanity okay uh it's a
Metroid Vania uh you you're Ash and you
uh you fight to either Embrace or uh
resist uh ancient eldrich Powers Okay
cool so what uh what platforms is
running on it will be steam yeah it's
going to be on Steam and uh PS4 in July
okay it's coming out in July
cool yeah you said it's like a metrov
Vania that's right up my alley um I
think I actually like incidentally I
think it's Symphony the night's like
20th anniversary like in a week or so
cool I think so so a lot of uh
Castlevania Metroid fan yeah yeah um all
the studio is a very I think all all
those Studios like really big on Metro
and Metroid a lot cool so it's very
inspired by that it's um they uh we it's
um it's kind of procedurally generated
but like the whole uh the whole area is
uh the general game uh no I don't
remember what I'm going to say yeah the
general um layout is set in stone okay
but uh the subsections are procedurally
generated so every time you reload it's
uh it's a new New Paths Okay cool so
here we'll uh we'll throw up footage
right now um do you want to play or you
want me to play oh please play I'll play
okay you I'll do uh the steering you you
can steer the
conversation
all right so uh yeah you can just try
out all the buttons and see what they do
okay
there's all right so Y is pretty
awesome yeah these are gravity Fields
basically you can't go up them gotcha
thank you all right okay I already got a
double jump nice so you play Ash your um
that's the the main character okay uh
she's a wander in a ruined world and uh
she basically has to find her way okay
and
through hordes and hordes of terrifying
enemies that you just saw one there two
what's uh what What's your title on the
development team like what kind of
things you work on with sun uh I'm the
art director oh awesome I was just going
to sa this s this is gorgeous thank you
yeah we have hand drawn style oh damn
yeah we have uh two animators and uh
another artist doing the aseton game
okay cool
yeah and then is that all out of
Montreal or is it remotely oh no we're
all in Montreal on the in one building
yeah we're full time on this oh awesome
yeah that's why it's coming so soon
because we can actually afford to sure
do I have like is that is this attack
limited do I have like a yeah uh you can
see the bullets the bullets yeah I was
like that seems too to not be limited
they they drop at random so you can okay
cool you'll find others there RPG
mechanics am I leveling up or is it more
like a actually there's a a central Hub
when you die you uh spawn back to the
hub and there's a skill tree there that
you can upgrade for permanent up
upgrades awesome and there's also perks
that you can find in game those are
interchangeable every run okay so like
just some uh some are just like more
abilities and uh oh if you go down yeah
oh cool nice yeah Secrets there's a lot
of those hidden everywhere so it's going
to be a lot of uh it's going to be a lot
of exploring to do okay that's what we
actually like yeah
yeah so did you say do you have like a
release window for this game at all July
cool yeah awesome it's uh we've been in
production for about a year now awesome
so yeah it's uh it's coming out in July
and uh it's going to be really fun cool
we have a lot of feedback already that
like people already like it so yeah it
feels really good we also uh just uh
finished the kickstarter oh awesome for
it and yeah it's uh we're going to get
we're going going to send out the alpha
soon to pretty much all the backers
awesome yeah so we're really looking for
feedback feedback on on this cool yeah
for those just joining the audience I do
have the twitch and YouTube chats up
here so uh feel free to ask questions
for Joanie um or I'll do my best to
monitor the chat while I'm I don't think
I can get over there does not look like
it nobody you can fall down though okay
I there's no fall damage oh awesome okay
that's good to know because I didn't
want to like screw up the stream by just
dying too much whoa all right cool I do
a Dodge this is where the fun begins oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
man oh man
so yeah this is uh the first horde that
you encounter in this level it's the
first it's the biggest hord it's like
the uh the challenge for
uh to measure how good you are
basically we'll
see oh I'm out of those that rail gun
ammo damn yeah that that was tough all
right but it's okay now you can actually
go to the skill tree and upgrade and get
more powers and it gets easier so you
respawn back there yeah okay here you
just have to uh go
up here we go oh cool yeah oh the
skillet Tre is like in the game back on
that's cool yeah we we we trying to do
as little UI as possible we wanted to
integrate everything cool so yeah that's
uh The Shield you have it breaks it's
like before you uh you take actually any
damage okay
kind of like that do you have what you
have a recommendation which uh I
personally y for Shields because I I
last longer okay but yeah that's just
the path basically cuz those are um
actually perks that you get okay yeah so
do I have any no sorry the skills yeah
do I have any points right now uh you
don't have a perk yet so you can't
unlock that okay but every triangle is
uh three nodes that you can fill in okay
so you can just like pick whatever you
want
cool
go that yeah it it costs eight you have
like 500 so you can fill all the all
three of them cool yeah and then you
unlock as you go oh awesome is that just
for the purpos of this build you have so
much no uh no it's just going to be
probably more actually oh dang yeah no
cuz like uh well also uh the costs
augments every time okay every time you
uh you spend more like now if you go to
any like now it costs 50 instead of four
right okay gotcha that makesense the
price goes up as you fill in the the
skill tree yeah is um is The Shield
thing passive or is that a is that it's
it's a skill so you already got it yeah
technically uh this would uh the area
you were in was uh the second region
okay that were that's going to be in the
fin final game so technically in the
first region you're going to get the two
skills that you see on the skill tree
right now okay so on in this region you
can find other uh
okay sweet I think I used as much as I
can right now awesome so now I'm just
going over here it looks like yeah all
right here we
go how much far how much how far into
away from this point was that horde I
just ran into not very far there you go
oh I see where I am there you go what
how do I activate that Shield oh you
don't it's uh the blue bar over your
perfect okay cool passive it's just like
yeah there's there's going to be a
bubble around you that breaks when it
breaks so you start taking damage okay
all right let's see if I do better this
time have a lot more Health than you did
they just start raining down yeah and
now you also have your four five uh yeah
gunshots oh the big ones actually push
you back
okay
yeah if you stay out of danger for a
while the shield regenerates oh awesome
yeah that was a huge waste all right
see if I can line
them yeah wow you got like six of them
at the same time does it just travel
through as many people as possible oh it
goes through all the map awesome if you
could see all the map it would go
through at
all and with the flying Monsters uh one
thing we uh we really liked is that you
can chain you can chain attacks in the
air so if you hit something you can jump
again oh perfect yeah yeah I think I
survived it unless this guy kills me
that'd be kind of ironic all right here
we go sweet get all this yeah
gold there we go and Treasure Chest
sweet what what is that Treasure Chest
it's like oh it's Thorns yeah cuz the
basically like U everything in this
region has come alive okay including
like the ceiling in the floor and
everything interesting there's eldrich
Powers
just abound okay so there a gravity well
right here yeah oh you picked up uh guns
uh gun uh shell oh gotta
yeah and right there is a skill Shrine
okay just go hit the
middle yeah gotcha that just give me a
new uh ability I'm assuming yeah cool
whoa yeah you get you get imbued whether
you like it or not well you could also
like never pick it up yeah so that's the
the Boost to literally make you go
through any gra gravity field
awesome it replaces your Dodge so if you
were using it that's what it
does
[Music]
go
nah I think you want to go right all
right
whoops it's okay like that one actually
is finicky for me but I don't play the
game a lot okay cuz I'm too busy doing
the art I think you want to go oh gosh
now I'm going back up above it all right
this makes sense now it's all coming
Treasure Chest
sweet oop oh man oh no got a little to
got overzealous in my combo
back I think you could have cheesed it
and just like gone left if you double
jump and then Dash in the air okay
there's a lot of places you can get with
just uh Dash interesting so I'm going
going to the left go
down yeah there we
go just uh pretty easy to bring up the
map just hold the trigger
yeah yeah we didn't want like same for
the Hub like we didn't want anything in
well as least as as little as possible
in the the actual UI okay so uh
everything is we try to put it in
game oh that's cool I think that just
like now she's like dashing in her
attacks too how I got that or is that
maybe that just oh that's just a dash
yeah that's just the pressing it didn't
realize it well it's a it replaces your
Dodge so you were used to like using
your Dodge so that's probably just what
happened right probably overthinking it
oh it's okay I understand I do the
same yeah I really like the r Style on
[Music]
this
oops for the art side we already like
had uh kind of like a
visual oh that's a new enemy dang we
already had like a style kind of setting
stone for uh with our last game sure so
we kind of just like like built from
there what was uh your last game jok
okay
yeah when did that release was that 2
years ago or was that that was
2015 okay yeah interesting yeah yeah I
remember playing
that we obviously went with a dark tone
yeah yeah I was going to say oh you can
destroy that yeah oh
perfect yeah they're spawned by the
Mages that you saw okay they just want
to block you in cuz they don't like you
yeah
doesn't seem like a lot of things like
me
game so how much like emphasis are you
putting on story or you kind of make put
putting like that on a back seat just so
you for now in any any version until I I
think the very last one we're going to
leave most of the story out okay so that
it's it's mostly like in the final
version and people get the full idea at
the same time okay but yeah there's
going to be story integrated in there
we're trying to do it as smoothly as
possible so you don't actually like get
stopped and have to listen or read story
bits okay oh I just see like a charge
attack I didn't know I
had yeah you have one you can charge up
yeah that one that that one you can do
up and down oh
cool oh sweet
okay
you're getting used to that yeah I know
it's it's really satisfying to use oh
that's going to be that's that's the fun
part the most fun part this is yeah oh
man these machine this machine graveyard
doesn't look too
inviting nether does a skull above me on
the map oh my God oh my God better
jum
oh d there you go you've done you've
done the whole the whole demo oh jeez
yeah that was fun we can uh jump back in
and show a little more of it we got like
five more minutes sure cool I think if
you load back in you're going to still
have your uh your shards cool awesome
yeah so I can rank up a little bit maybe
yeah awesome yeah that that demo was
done really short but oh no you didn't
oh you don't have
them oh H either
way but yeah it's uh we we just wanted
to give a taste basically okay cool
which I think worked definitely yeah
know it feels really oh these are G who
you did you picked up a lot of ammo for
some reason there we
go will those be on the ground long
enough like for me to go back oh they
stay forever oh perfect so I can any any
drop actually as well use one right now
oh yeah any any drops uh actually stays
in there forever so gotcha yeah for a
while we had uh help drop but in the in
our newest newest uh builds we're going
to have probably
a potions that you're you can you're
going to have like a few per round and
then you can use them okay as you wish
and then you can replenish them but
yeah okay so I see what you meant by
like chaining the aerial attacks
mhm it it it mostly works when you have
a lot of aial in EN
but
it's yeah the gun is fun but it has a
lot of
drawbacks or push backs yeah well also
drawback because you
can you can just like end up in spikes
and it could be the end of you yep all
right we'll see to end it we'll see how
I do without the upgrades here now that
you've done it once yeah you have more
bullets this time around that's
true
nice oh man I feel so much less safe
without that bubble Shield I know yeah
when I when I usually like play this and
I get to that part I just like run
around until it recovers I'm out of
bullets regenerates oh no try to isolate
him it's okay you're almost done
though close yeah oh man I'm close to
dying too oh
no
oh Dam so close though like that was the
all that would uh spawn so man all right
well uh cool well so this is uh we'll go
back to the skill screen quick show
people to Tre woman last time before we
uh switch
off just kind of want to see what this
is so this is the the strength path more
this is the attack you were charging up
okay gotcha
yeah increases your gun's damage it
seemed like it already had like pretty
high damage oh you can you can go all
the way like you can go like pretty much
gun path if you wanted like Tech pack
bath yeah just like have the gun to be
maximized and everything cool awesome
sweet so that was sunnd from Thunder
Lotus games who also made Joe ton uh
Joannie thanks so much for coming out to
show us appreciate and uh yeah we love
having people on we're going to have uh
dimol games come on to show us where the
water tastes like wine next but again
that is sunnd it will be out on Steam in
July yeah Steam and PS4 Steam and PS4 in
July for my thunderers games so uh yeah
I just played it that was really fun I'm
looking forward to playing more but uh
Joanie thanks so much for showing to us
thank you yeah and have a great GDC
we'll see you around thank you awesome
see you around thanks so much for those
just joining on YouTube or twitch or
Gamespot where ever you happen to be
watching this we are uh doing our Indie
mix GDC 2017 live stream uh we're just
swapping out we have four more games to
show we showed uh punch Planet fighting
game and we just showed sun to Metroid
Vania now we have where the water tastes
like wine I have yanan nordhagen here
going to bring on right now to uh show
off this game uh we can jump into it in
a second got Eric Tay has setting this
stuff up for us yanan so nice to have
you yeah nice to be here thanks yeah so
uh so you used to I met you first when
you were with Fullbright company working
on yeah so you're programming for them
and then you branched off to do your own
thing with dimb yeah exactly cool um and
this is it uh where the water tastes
like wine awesome so we can jump right
into this then yeah so this is uh a game
about traveling and telling stories uh
it's all about kind of the idea of
American folklore um this this idea that
uh as
you're uh as stories and songs get kind
of passed around from person to person
they change and grow okay so I'm going
to go um I'm I'm this character right
here sort of a personification of the
idea of of folklore um I'm going to
start by skeleton with a bindle that's
right kind of a hobo skeleton so uh
there's there's a lot of text in this
game um we'll we'll kind of gloss over
this on stream here but um I'm going to
this place seeing a little like uh
Adventure kind of thing this is a a
little story Choice thing uh I get to
look at this it's a family uh who's
trying to sell me a violin for money um
I don't have that amount of money so I'm
going to say no um sure I'll buy this
violin um so they uh here we learn like
oh my gosh this is uh one of the members
of the family this girl it's her violin
Louise Ames she says she shouts at you
as the the car peels away uh so that's
interesting um I'm going to leave the
violin uh behind uh cuz I don't want it
but when I've when I've done this uh I
got a story out of it like I can tell
people the story of uh this weird violin
that I had this this deal so the title
of this game uh where the water tastes
like wine is this line that shows up in
a bunch of different folk songs and
stories and things like that and I chose
that for the game because um it sort of
uh has this idea of um this this thing
gets passed along from song to song from
place to place all sorts of different
people it in their in their thing and so
that's sort of what you're doing in this
game is you're taking these stories and
you're uh you're telling them forward
but the important part is actually these
people that you meet here um you sit
around this campfire uh with various
folks okay uh this is someone we've met
before uh her name is Alia she's a Blues
singer and she sold her soul to the
devil for the power to play guitar well
that's uh is Alia A Grateful Dead song
uh it is actually yeah that's uh that's
right
um that's where the name comes from
that's the connection I'm making uh so
um she tells us a little bit uh she's
already told us a bit about herself cuz
we talked to her before okay but now um
you know talking to her a bit more um
she tells
us all this when the devil found me I
was on the edge of that Cliff he had
seen deep inside me he knew and we made
a
deal so then she asks you you know hey
I'm in the mood for a for a good St I'm
telling you something about myself so
you know I want to hear something
something from you and uh I've got an
entire collection of stories here that
I've I've built up these are tarot cards
these are tarot cards yeah so that's
sort of a a hook into the the mystical
side of things this as you can tell from
this woman who sold her soul to the
devil this is not uh entirely realistic
game about traveling and telling stories
there's a little bit of the American
folklore kind of creeps into the world
there's this this Fantastical uh
psychedelic surreal uh aspect effect of
things so um I'm going to tell her this
story cuz I think that's a happy one see
what she says this is again one of these
stories that I found wandering around
previously um she likes that one uh I
get a little bit you can see this eye at
the top sort of starting to open that
that tells me she's liking these stories
we're kind of connecting on a level if
we get far enough along um I'll get to
see more of her story that's how I got
to chapter to here eventually I might
get to see kind of her true self uh what
she's what she is really like um so uh I
told her a story about faith she's going
to tell me something about faith trust
things like that so she says uh when I
met the devil he looked like a man deep
sunken eyes the color of a peach pit his
smile like a broke Branch he looked no
more or less trustworthy than any other
white man I had knowed in my short
life uh so this this writing by the way
this is by uh G Jackson who's an
incredibly talented writer um she's
currently at Kotaku but she's worked for
a bunch of uh different places in the
past cool each of these characters is
written by a different person so we have
uh 16 different characters that each
have their own story and they've each
been written by by someone um a bunch of
names that people may have heard of uh
writing this stuff really happy to have
these talented talented authors and so
different characters will uh will you
know like react and respond differently
to different stories you tell them yeah
exactly so they have different
preferences about what sort of stories
they might want to hear um and of course
they've got you know their own own stuff
that they're trying to to get across
okay um so I'm going to keep trying to
tell her the sort of things she's in the
mood for right now um she like that one
also and you can see that I'm kind of
making it along here the time's also
passing right now so uh you know this is
night time but when the Sun rises I'll
I'll be done telling stories so I need
to try and get get through this this by
then okay um yeah there's not many
things colored folks can use to get free
you work twice as hard and get half as
much I thought money was a ticket out
but money come and go like everything
else so I had told her a story about
freedom and like the the freedom of the
road and things and so she's telling me
about how she thought being rich would
would get her freedom but didn't work
out for her
okay she wants a funny story this art
style is really striking thanks yeah
this is a so we're doing this kind of
hybrid 2D 3D thing all the character
stuff is in uh this 2D which is gorgeous
um our artist is fantastic at this uh
and then we we also have that 3D world
that we were looking at
before cool so tell her a funny story
here why
not so she's reacting really well these
stories then yeah so I you know I have
an idea because I've um been playing
this game for a while I have an idea of
what what sort of stories these are and
what people will like and and react to
and things like that so you know I'm I'm
and I understand what my story list is
if I didn't have if I hadn't done quite
as much stuff if I hadn't had as much I
wouldn't have much Choice here um and
that's not too bad because as you can
see there's uh there's a lot of
different categories here right so she
has a bunch of things to say and I can
only hear so much of it every time so I
can either if I want like more pieces of
her story I can either uh kind of extend
out the convers that I have with her or
I can play multiple times and the next
time I meet her I can maybe ask
different things or or share different
stuff okay um so I'm going to tell the
story of this gunshot man that I
met and these are yeah yeah the so the
little the little vignette things uh are
are also great writing they're really
spectacular little stories where you get
to choose the outcome and you get to or
not not necessarily the outcome actually
but you get to choose kind of what what
sort of story it might be so there's
depending on the different ways you look
at something it might be a scary story
or it might be a love story you know
these things these things change so
you're going around swapping these
stories and getting new ones from people
and telling your own is there is there
an endgame in mind or is this or is it
you know strictly for the enjoyment of
the writing and for learning these new
characters yeah mostly so so it is a
narrative game so as you go go through
this um the what you're what you're
trying to get is uh you're trying to
uncover the story of all these
characters there is however um sort of a
a goal to find them all to do that um
and along the way it's a little bit
challenging to survive in this harsh
thing you know you are you are a hobo
right you're you're carrying your bindle
you don't have a lot of money uh you
don't have a lot to eat things like that
you're living the life that these people
are as well so it's a little bit
challenging to get all the way uh West
for example if you're heading to
California um I think tell one last
story I'm going to tell the one that we
actually picked up a second ago um oops
actually that was the wrong one but
that's
fine um she actually didn't like that
one so she responded poorly to that okay
uh whoops but she still tells me a
little bit about what her what her deal
is I was beautiful once you can't tell
but I was beautiful once and then the
sun's come up so uh we're done we're
done talking to her um is one more thing
to tell
me thought it would last forever do you
understand I was not just a star I was
an inventor no one played guitar like me
no one I deserved what I had I thought
it would last forever it should have so
probably next time we meet her she might
tell us more about yeah there we go
chapter three she might tell us more
about the downfall she had this thing
she sold her soul to the devil she was
playing guitar and maybe next time uh we
learn what what went wrong cuz deals
with the de devil never go well right
this over this overw world map is a
scale United States yeah it is so we
we're here in Georgia you can see
Atlanta behind me there and we're about
to cross over into uh state line into
Alabama um and then I'm I'm going to
walk along here I could actually uh I
could hitchhike although uh likely many
people will pick me up I probably
wouldn't pick him up right who would
yeah gigantic hos skeleton but I'm going
to actually uh hear a story here this is
a chance I get to have um this guy says
oh I heard this story it's it's great
it's 10% true okay sure um and he tells
us the story of a violin where the owner
is the only one who can play it right
and sort of wow hey this sounds really
familiar this is a lot like that violin
story we we had before um so this is
this is an example of like a story
that's kind of been told around and come
back to you maybe a little big bitter uh
bigger and a little better than it was
before people kind of embellishing it
and and uh telling you more so I'm going
to um actually have a list here of all
the stories I've got and I can go and
look and see uh that one actually
leveled up it became a level two story
instead of level one gotcha um and so
how does that affect like when you relay
this story like if it's leveling up a
story how does that factor in well so we
saw that that uh sort of um Sun meter at
the top of the the conversation thing
and so like that progresses at a certain
speed um and the the more uh the better
these stories you tell then the more the
it'll kind of resonate with that person
and you can have a better chance of sort
of getting to know them and uh learning
more about them okay I'm going to go
talk or I'm going to go see what's
happening here in this
story walk along the tracks for an hour
towards the smell of the coal baking in
the Sun the train is idling at the
station sputtering exhausted a child
Paces up and down the line of black
carriages clutching a bundle of rags to
her chest she cranes her neck figuring
the height of the cars um I'll I'll say
hello to her you scared her half to
death she stares at you absolutely
petrified as you approach it was an
accident she
Whispers all you can see in the Heap of
blankets she carries In Her Arms is the
infant's tiny leg pale and
blue so she's carrying for some reason a
dead child um yeah so this this game uh
sort of the mood of this game is this
idea that uh
uh the American dream isn't here for
everybody uh and everyone you meet and a
lot of these vignettes kind of Express
this this sadness and this frustration
um and sort of the idea behind the title
uh where the water tastes like wine
there there is no such place right
there's a lot of people searching for
the promised land searching for El
Dorado searching for all sorts of uh
their their heart's desire the American
dream uh and you never find it because
it's not actually uh a place you can
find um so here we are uh I've got it's
like night is falling you can see the
sun sun setting here um so I'm going to
go ahead and Camp one more
time uh talk to someone else this is as
it says uh as you get tired you start
your health starts going down and things
like that so I need to need to find this
uh campfire and and start resting here
okay uh just to to clarify what um like
platforms are you aiming for with this
is going to be uh PC Mac Linux on Steam
and then um we've uh PS4 and Xbox one as
well cool so yeah to start you don't
have like a release window yet uh no
it's going to be sometime this year um
and that's all we're ready to say at
this point cool but yeah um did you want
to show us any more for that or that's
kind of that was yeah that was kind of
it we uh we finished with that last
character and we saw them transform kind
of into their their true self and uh
yeah show us what's going on cool so
yeah cool so yeah that's uh so it's
yanan nordhagen from dim Bol games we
will uh be showing a few more games
throughout uh I don't know if you want
to play any more or you want to I can uh
I'll wander around a little bit maybe
see us more this over find here yeah
exactly um I really like the this uh
this Overworld style it's kind of like a
hand drawn yeah we were trying to match
the uh the same illustration style that
you saw in the in the character thing um
I'm going to see what I
can find here if this is uh a new
thing two men identical stand Sentry
over a third body half covered with a
canvas sheet might as well grab a shovel
being that you're here the man in front
says bearing a body interesting uh sure
I'll help okay you and John dig a hasty
grave while his brother keeps the
lookout closer now you see the corpse
shares their face Tom was the oldest by
an hour John says though I guess George
and me we've got a few hours on him now
so two brothers killed their their
triplet something like that weird mean
son of a [__] beat the life out of us
did on our folks that way got to be too
much so we said last night we'd do him
in kin only gets you so far George went
and dragged him out here to do it I
would have helped you know but George is
the strong one out of me and him I thank
Jesus he's gone I do I thought I'd have
trouble saying that but I don't all
right wow I I probably wouldn't know
what to say there either either pray or
not respect
John Squints at the body Tom's nose
wasn't bent like that he says
uncertainly and then despair floods his
face he looks ready to throw up you
leave him to it so it seems like maybe
they they murdered the wrong
brother uh so this the vignette writing
was also done by we have a number of
really talented uh writers working on
stuff like this again it's sort of a
bunch of uh bunch of great people doing
all this stuff for
us so cool and this is all like play
taking place across the American South
or you we're right now um in in the
south southeastern United States but
actually the the game has the whole
United States you can go from the you
know up from uh Maine all the way to
California Oregon cool all over so yeah
no uh no Alaska Hawaii or Hawaii though
they're bit out you can't really
hitchhike there yeah exactly so cool
cool awesome
sweet so yanan nordhagen thanks so much
for coming on to show us uh where the
water tastes like wine my pleasure oh
that's an appropriate uh pause screen
San Francisco postcard pause menu
awesome so this will be uh again you
have don't have a specific release
window yet but it'll be PC Mac Linux and
then PS4 and Xbox One yep later this
year awesome thanks so much for showing
us and have a good GDC appreciate you
coming on cool for everybody joining us
whether you're on Twitch or YouTube or
Gamespot we are here doing the Indie mix
GT 2017 live stream we uh have shown a
few games shown where the water tastes
like wine shown punch Planet fighting
game and we shed Sund the Metro Vania
now we have Beacon coming on and uh have
our next
guest so uh I'll let him introduce
himself hi I'm Kean zip from monothetic
nice to meet you Kean and uh we're going
to jump into Beacon can you tell us
while we're loading up tell us about
this game that we're about to see so
Beacon's a Sci-Fi Action Rog like that
plays like a twin stick shooter uh
you've crashed on an unidentified alien
planet
and
uh uh you need to sort of run through
the planet explore find gear upgrades uh
collect DNA off of enemies that you've
killed cool and when you eventually die
you're given the opportunity to
integrate any of that DNA you've
collected in your previous life uh to
sort of change your statistics to pick
your play style and also give you a
chance of getting mutations cool yes
we're just going to hand the controller
to someone off screen while me and you
talk about it I'm sure I have a lot of
questions but uh yeah cool so we're
going to jump right into Beacon right
here just a pause menu but uh give the
control over to somebody so we can show
this off uh so when uh what just to
start I guess what platforms what kind
of uh do you have a release window yet
at all for bean uh we're focusing on PC
right now but we're also planning to
release on uh Xbox One on Mac and PS4 as
well if we can cool a release date
hopefully by the end of the year maybe
early 2018 though okay so there's like
Rog like elements is like a procedural
generation as well yes the levels are
all randomly generated it's a very
faction Rich world there's a many
different factions that you can find so
every time that you play again the level
will be regenerated uh different
factions will be populating different
areas of the game like there might be
droids one time you play it there will
be more bugs the other times you play it
okay all of the items and mutations are
all very heavily based on those factions
as well so for example if you you loot a
lot of DNA from the robots and you
integrate that DNA into yourself uh if
you get mutations in the next life
you'll start to to maybe your arm will
get replaced by a robot arm for example
okay interesting I I like the art style
so
far so you said uh where does this take
place said just sci-fi like different
planet uh an unidentified alien planet
that you crash landed on gotcha so
everything's sort of been destroyed in
the wreckage except for your clone Bay
and your weapon
cool I'm I imagine it be it's going to
be semi difficult game uh yeah you're
definitely not going to beat it on the
first try okay
death is sort of a one of the main uh
core components of the loop as well so
being a Rog like you're going to die a
lot we try to turn death into a mechanic
though with the cloning uh with the DNA
being able to be switched when you die
instead of just a hard reset for the
game
cool oh damn you like fire retardant
armor you can dodge over the fire
gotcha so he's just going through the
tutorial right now going through all the
base mechanics so Dodge roll
grenade
cool there's a lot of little puzzles and
traps like that as well that are uh
placed throughout the levels
okay and so if I were if you were to
load up a new game right now the
beginning would be
different this is the tutorial so that's
the same every time but after you get
through the tutorial the level will be
randomly generated cool
obviously like collecting like upgrades
when you can yeah there's a lot of
different types of items uh so you can
get new weapons you can get new grenade
mods this is an auxiliary item so this
is a a reusable item that has a cool
down every time you use it okay cool so
you can get something better than like a
you start with a Plasma Pistol every
time yeah okay
dang that looks pretty
effective
this is a cool looking world that
reminds me kind of like I like the
isometric View and everything that kind
of almost top down yeah we started off
in 2D actually so that's uh partly where
the style comes from and then when we we
started switching to doing everything in
3D we wanted to keep that kind of
similar 2D perspective okay so it's
still it's rendering in in 3D
perspective but the the field of view is
pretty low so it still looks a little
bit 2D brass
Beast sounds intimidating so this is a a
special weapon variant that he found in
a little secret zone so that was a an
old version of Freya up there who died
in a previous life before she was
recloned okay so that that old dead
clone left a uh a weapon back there that
she kind of tinkered with before she
died and now this new clone of frya
found it on her dead
body he's going to keep the shotgun okay
so you can cover one you can carry one
weapon curious see how this shotgun work
works so this is the variant of the the
normal ship shotgun weapon so this one
uh it fires out extra projectiles that
will bounce off of the environment once
okay so you can kind of sometimes get a
lucky shot where one of the the balls
that it shoots out will bounce off and
hit an enemy
okay what's it like the there's a lot of
variety in the enemies I'm seeing the
shielded enemies right now uh yeah
between each faction there's about uh 5
to eight enemies Perfection right now so
that was a couple of the Droid enemies
he'll probably run into some bugs at
some point oh okay are those the two
factions droids and bugs uh those are
the two main ones right now there's also
uh the native faction which they have
some little Raptor enemies uh also some
little bugs that roll around okay when
you find them yeah how much emphasis are
you putting on like a narrative cuz
that's kind of tough with like Rogue
like yeah that's something that we're
trying to balance so there is a
definitely a lot of lore and a lot of
background into the world but we try not
to force that on anyone so there are
narrative elements that spawn throughout
the game and you can when you find them
you'll open them up and there will be a
text prompt you can read but those are
all completely optional we don't want to
force anyone to have to read a bunch of
texts if they just want to go around
shooting robots
Okay yeah when I play rogle I kind of I
play it for the the systems and
mechanics more than I play for the
narrative
but there definitely is a lot of that
background information though if you
want to sort of sniff it out and learn
more about the world just to lend flavor
for those who want to go looking for it
yeah
cool so he's heading into a a heavily
fortified prism Fortress right now this
is going to lead to a loot
area now he's on the the surface of the
planet
okay so was the overarching objective
like if I get into a new game and I'm
trying to you know like upgrade my
character and but like uh what's what's
the destination that I'm trying to get
to like to survive long enough to get to
so the main goal of the game uh since
you've crashed on this planet you need
to find your distress Beacon to to to
signal for escape so that's uh the end
goal of the entire game the the level
end goal though is you need to find your
beacon locator which is sort of a a
little piece of Machinery that was
dropped as the ship was crashing that
will help you locate your beacon okay so
that's kind of the level on flag
cool so there's levels how many levels
are you looking at or do you uh there's
final game probably about six levels
this build is three and then say you
beat one will that like will you if you
die in the second level you have to go
back to the beginning of the game or
just second it resets back to the first
level every time you die that's sort of
the security protocol over cloning Bay
every time you die uh you get recloned
back to the cloning Bay at the beginning
of the game to to retry to find the
beacon okay so it's kind of it's
possible she's been trapped on this
planet for years just constantly trying
to find her Beacon dying and then being
recloned to try again okay so you'll
definitely run into a lot of the
previous bodies from the other freas who
have died attempting to find the beacon
okay gotcha I imagine like by the time
you get to the end of the sixth level
you'll kind of things will be pretty
tense yeah hoping you don't
die the enemies will keep evolving as
well the the further you get in the game
like more difficult enemies will start
spawning more often and in less
telegraphed
areas what uh what kind of inspiration
were you guys drawing from uh what kind
of Roes do you like to play uh binding
of Isaac's probably my favorite that was
initially what inspired me to want to
make a ro like in the first place with
uh Edmond McMillan who made that right
yeah
cool you played uh you play any like
Spelunky uh Aaron definitely does guy
playing the game I haven't played it so
much though he loves funky yeah yeah
it's uh that game's fantastic I I used
to play it all the time but I haven't in
a while but yeah I I love Rog leges I
mean like there's like that big resur of
Rog likes in recent years you know like
5 years ago you started seeing
everything like after Spelunky and FTL
and everything uh what are the
advantages like how many people are
working on Beacon uh about six or seven
right now but we've mostly been working
part-time the last few years we're
trying to push to get more of us
full-time though to bring the game to
release gotcha sure it's great to be at
GDC right with the Indie mix team yeah
awesome it's especially easy cuz I live
about a block away from here oh
awesome yeah it's nice to have all the
developers in one place for GC and San
Francisco yeah love having people in and
everything so he found the key in the
loot area and now he's going to collect
his loot
okay there like a risk reward involved
like some areas you might not have to go
into because they're difficult even
though they might yield more loot yeah
definitely so this area the there's
always one loot area with a major
upgrade that spawns in every level okay
so you kind of have to explore and find
it there's also a lot of little secrets
and extra loot like tiny crates you can
find pickups and health in that you can
uh find if you just explore a bit more
some of them are locked behind puzzles
as well so you have to figure out like
how do I get up here how do I get this
side okay damn these enemies are pretty
fast yeah that's that's the fastest one
definitely you're not careful to just
chase after you and beat you down I was
noticing there not like a lock on it's
all the red analog stick right
uh yeah right now we have to do some
improvements to the
control damn that looked tough so now
that he's died uh he'll go to the
reconstitution screen and he'll get a
chance to integrate any DNA he's found
to change his statistics cool they only
found one piece of DNA unfortunately not
a great one in my opinion I always
prefer upgrading speed and critical
chance if I can okay each faction also
uh affects different statistics so if
you prefer a a certain statistic you
might want to focus on trying to kill
enemies of a specific faction that are
going to drop statistics that you like
more
okay he didn't get a mutation either but
every time you integrate a piece of DNA
there's a chance that it'll uh give you
a mutation on your next clone oh cool so
that'll physically change your character
and give you a a larger gameplay
altering effect like for example if you
put a lot of the bug DNA in there's a
chance that you'll grow a carrus on your
back and then uh you won't take any
damage if your back is facing the
oh that's awesome you don't take any
damage at all yeah what can you talk
about any other mutations you might get
uh you can grow horns on your head sort
of okay so then when you roll into
enemies you'll damage them cuz the horns
whack into them when you roll a kind
like a bull charge yeah so you're just
gradually becoming an alien through
Evolution so you can get up to five
mutations and they all uh show up
visually on the player as well so you
can get pretty mutated the the more DNA
you integrate
awesome so that's kind of a part of the
The Narrative as well is by the time she
gets rescued how mutated is she like are
they even going to want to rescue her at
this point with all the the weird
mutations that she's got oh that's
awesome this is not what we expected to
pick up we thought we were looking for a
human but we found this horn carrus
thing what kind of uh those trees upside
down yeah they're they're kind of like
weird a little Al trees they have some
fruit on the top too the Flora and Fauna
around here aren't aren't too normal
that's awesome
looking what what do we know about this
protagonist I think you kind of talk a
little bit about her but uh she she
works in the private military sector
okay she was kind of just doing a a
shipment run and you don't really know
why she's crashed on the planet that's
part of the mystery in the game that you
unlock the more you play so that's kind
of explained more the the deeper you get
into the game the more narrative
elements you explore you'll get more
background information on that like what
is this planet you don't know why these
Droids are here why
they're you're in such big numbers like
why they have such huge structures on
this planet
sure it's all kind of alien to her too
okay and you said like uh I forgot what
we were talking about just now the The
Narrative itself is kind of unfolds as
you go but you're you know it's kind of
like taking a backseat or you you want
to stress that it's there for people
that want to find G
what was that you said it started in 2D
and then you decided to go somewhere
else with it with with the isometric
view that was mainly because of we were
all 3D artists by trade okay and uh when
we got to animating the characters it
was it's pretty difficult in 2D
sometimes so we decided let's just
switch it to 3D and we tried to emulate
the 2D feel of it a little bit okay but
now that it's in 3D uh you can see the
there's a lot more depth to it like when
you you walk around the balts they shift
as you move instead of just being a
solid 2D element
okay so these are some of the natives
you said these
Raptors
uhoh so all the different enemies drop
different items as well if you kill the
Raptors you'll get native DNA uh they
also Drop Eggs sometimes that you can
eat
okay presumably for health yeah okay so
he's shooting the health off the tree
there oh interesting
okay
cool yeah for those just joining and
asking this is uh Beacon from uh
monothetic this is uh yeah twin six
shooters you can see isometric and uh
we'll be releasing on PC Xbox One
confirmed right now yes hopefully PS PS4
late 2017 early 2018 cool and yeah just
joining uh if you're in the YouTube chat
the twitch chat the games spot chat we
have those up so if you have any
questions for Keith in here or myself uh
obviously he knows way more about this
game than I do but we uh have another
two Indie developers coming on uh we're
going to be showing Fallen Legion and
Tacoma after this but yeah right now
we're looking at Beacon which is a Rog
likee sci-fi twin sck
shooter which looks pretty die
soon yeah if you're just joining uh
we're kind of
screwed melee
him oh God damn I saw he picked I think
he picked up a DNA though at least one
plus Health from that
dinosaur uh dinosaurs dropped the in a
lot cool can you eventually get like
dinosur M you can get dinosaur mutations
hopefully you'll get one now you can
grow a a tail that'll make you move
faster you can get scales oh awesome so
this is one of the mutations this is a
prism mutation the robots so now he has
a chance when he gets a critical hit to
go into slow motion for a few
seconds so it'll make it a lot easier to
sort of aim and plan out your shots when
you get the the slow motion effect kind
of like a bullet time mechanic almost
that's
awesome did that did that mutation come
from the dinosaur d uh no that came from
the robot one so now she has those
little connectors on her arms okay
interesting so you carry that mutation
into the next time you get cloned uh
yeah mutations lasts about three lives
right now so DNA is permanent until you
get a mutation and then that piece of
DNA is locked in your genome until the
mutation is is fixed Okay so until you
get a mutation you can mix and match DNA
however you want but once you get that
mutation that that piece of DNA is
locked in until uh you've played three
times
okay and now he's running into some of
the bug enemies they sort of uh they're
one of the Native factions of the planet
they've lived on there they kind of
evolved there there uh the robots and
them are sort of in a constant war in
the background of the game so you find
them fighting each other sometimes while
you're just running through yourself
okay like this Landmark it looks like
the bugs infested uh one of the prism
outposts so they kind of killed all the
Droids that were there already yeah
okay she said you'll gradually find out
if you care about the story you'll find
out what the like the droids are doing
here what this planet is cuz they do
definitely have goals they a reason
they're on this planet
okay they seem pretty aggressive his
grenade just went right past
them just use a steroid injector what
was that so that's a a pickup that's a
onetime use item the steroid injector
that gives you a increased resistance
for about 16 seconds so once you
activate that you take very little
damage while it's
active a couple other pickups are the
adrenaline injector so you'll get a
super fast speed and stamina I'm going
to regen for a little bit
okay so how many how many times like
when you're when you're playing from a
fresh new game how many times do you
think you play through the first mission
before you get past it I'd say probably
for a new player two to three times
okay but we sort of definitely want to
to have a curve where you need to to
play a few times you need to get a bit
of DNA and some mutations to sort of uh
increase your power so can keep
progressing further into the game
sure I like how the character visually
changes based on mutations too
yeah eventually just be like a Droid
dinosaur bug like a hybrid of all forms
yeah you can mix all of the factions DNA
together so you can get a mutation from
every faction just be like a a hideous
mess we found the brass past again there
we go is that is that not too common uh
there's about five of those weapon
variants now so he got the the same one
twice okay but every time that that uh
weapon will spawn there it'll be a
random weapon okay
gotcha so we'll
uh assuming he dies no offense but we'll
uh probably go till the next death
before we uh thank you for coming on and
swap you out but yeah this looks fun I
want to dive into this a little more
got a piece of DNA
too volatile one that's a good D that
look really good is that speed Health in
some I didn't see what else it was like
plus Health Plus speed and then minus
two other statistics so there's four
types of DNA there's base DNA which is
mostly going to be a one positive and
one negative statistic uh volatile is a
lot more randomized in a lot larger
amounts but it also will have uh like
two positives and two negatives usually
okay and then fortified is a it's always
just two to three positive fully
statistics but it's less likely to give
you a
mutation okay so there's sort of a
little meta game with like which pieces
do I want to integrate do I want to
focus on stats or mutation for here some
more bugs right slow motion bug oh so
that's that uh mutation you the Droid
one NP got this Lev
otion cool so we'll probably have to
wrap this up unfortunately now I want at
the end oh
cool good chasing it's a positive way to
end
it is that the beacon you're looking for
it's the beacon located oh
okay so now it's sort of giving her a
hint like you need to go this way to get
to the the beacon but at the end of
every level you'll find one of
those cool
well fortunately that's all the time we
have kein thanks so much for coming on
to show us Beacon that is a isometric
twin stick Rog likee SciFi shooter in
which you uh kind of manipulate your
clones DNA to evolve and survive on the
planet uh that will be PC Xbox One and
then hopefully PS4 you said and uh later
2017 is when you're hoping to release
yes possibly early 2018 we'll see okay
cool and so yeah if you're joining us we
are doing uh the Indie mix live stream
here at Gamespot we're having a few
Indie developers come in to show off the
games before they do the Indie mix event
tonight in San Francisco um yeah just
for more on Beacon stay stay tuned to
Gamespot uh we're going to swap Kean out
thanks for much to coming on to show us
thanks for having us awesome thanks so
much uh yeah for those joining we have
the YouTube chat in the gam spot and the
twitch chats open uh we're going to
rotate another developer in here soon
but yeah if you have any questions for
myself or anybody coming on we're going
to show Fallen Legion next um it's going
to be like sounds like a kind of crazy
game like a RPG PS RPG on PS 4 Vita um
it's like a control up to four
characters in this battle system we'll
jump into that a second when we have uh
Spencer I Believe come on to uh show off
the game and talk about it um so we're
just miking them up and everything uh
but like I said if you have any uh
questions in the YouTube or twitch or
Gamespot chats I'm happy to answer
anything I know but uh like I said I'm
really excited because we're they're
showing off these games and I'm getting
to learn more before uh Indie mix events
start tonight and
everything uh yeah so we will have uh we
have a lot of stuff going up this week
gam spot Wednesday we have Arcane
Studios Raph col anonio coming in to
show us prey for about an hour that'll
be Wednesday right after the lobby our
live show which I host which you can
come check out um we uh we'll be showing
prey we'll be working on a new show that
we actually just started Jake Decker and
myself just started reboot uh kind of
like a take a deeper look uh opinion
editorial show I'm ring up Spencer right
now he's going to show us Fallen Legion
um so so far today we have shown punch
Planet the fighting game we've shown
sunnd in metroidvania we just showed uh
where the water tastes like wine was a
more uh you know narrative driven kind
of dialogue heavy uh game from dimal
games yanan nordhagen used to be a full
bright company working on gone home but
he branched off to do his own thing um
and then we just showed Beacon which is
the isometric sci-fi twin stick shooter
we just showed and now in a few minute
seconds like hopefully we're just going
to put Spencer on a talk about uh Fallen
Legion which sounds like pretty crazy
game should be fun to watch um we're
going to have someone off screen playing
for us so we can talk more about it but
uh yeah we have a lot of coverage this
week for GDC so be sure to stay tuned to
Gamespot and everything and uh we will
uh we'll keep you posted on everything
going on like I said it's great to have
these Indie de developers in and uh you
know show off all their games a lot of
small teams that make the trip to San
Francisco this week so we're happy to
all right cool uh Spencer I believe
right yeah Spencer we're going to have
you come on hey I'm Mike nice to meet
you Spencer nice to meet you I brought
something for you from from Fallen
Legion oh sweet sweet it's one of our
little buttons here got pin sweet
awesome uh so tell me about Fallen
Legion yeah so Fallen Legion is is an
action RPG emphasis on action you're
going to control four characters at the
same time in real time okay and on PS4
you play as Princess Cal and she's
trying to save her crumbling Kingdom
from an economic collapse now she's not
a quest to save the world it's really
more like a personal Quest so um so
while you're playing this game you're
going to be making choices on how to
rule the kingdom and these choices will
permanently change the story okay and
you're going to be doing these like in
the middle of these really Fierce and
intense fights okay so right now we're
going to pick a team here so um damn he
looks like someone I want on my team
yeah he's zakar is a really good
Defender all of her characters all these
characters here are weapons that she
brought to life using this magical
grimore that she's carrying oh milir is
uh Thor's no yes th Thor's hammer yes
Thor yeah you got it yeah so uh so we
picked less longus is really good at
extending com and Winchester is a really
good
at adding debuffs to characters so she's
like she has a skill that can like U
make enemies stop using spells okay I
like the art style it's like an old
school RPG kind of look to it thank you
yeah you know we're really proud like of
the art so we want to make like a really
beautiful 2D game sure what uh Spencer
what role do you play on the team uh
well we are in Indie de Indie studio so
many roles from uh programmer to
director to designer the wrer to
sometimes VFX artist all right let me
rephrase that what don't you do on the
team um the music and and the artwork
and the drawing people in the chat are
complimenting the music as well oh yeah
we have like a rockestra rock orchestra
style theme like I can't take any credit
for that like that's all that's all of
our composers work what on Earth is
going on here right now we have we have
four characters here each character is M
to a different butt okay so you press
Circle sua car attack you press X La
will attack you press square Winchester
will attack you press the L1 Buton you
can block so you all attacking and
defense happens in real time so if you
block right before an enemy strikes you
can stagger them just like that with
launch so you have to keep track of not
only just all four of your characters
but also all the enemy characters okay
and if you press down in Triangle you
can heal so every time you attack you
recover a little bit of magic Mir Cal
has three spells by default one is an
attack called Cassandra's coil where she
shoots a bunch of fireballs and then she
has alious blessing which which is a
healing spell and uh up and triangle is
to revive one Fallen character okay so
so you like so triangle right now is
mapped to the healer is that her in the
back so yeah princess seal she always
uses match in the back so so it's always
mapped triangle is always mapped to her
okay yeah so right now we're fighing
some Bandits here and if these Bandits
they do physical they do mlay attack
they also furl their axes right okay and
if you perfect block right before an ax
hit so you can have to reflect it back
after like just like that oh damn good
timing
on multiple
levels yeah and so there are advantages
to like attacking with um forgive me I
forget the names of the characters Zar
is the guy with the sword lus is the
girl with the spear and Winchester is
the girl in the back with the gun and
there are different advantages to each
one's attacks obviously like I'm
assuming Winchester do you want to like
do range to maybe hit people toward the
other range characters toward the back
maybe or yeah so so they had they have
different they have different abilities
to Target characters when they use a
Super Attack so you see that glowing
blue flame spot on the fifth slot so the
character that attacks there does a
death blow so the the death blow is
change by characters if Zar is the last
is a person on that spot he'll jump in
the air and slam down his sword with
Skys SPL that does heavy damage but
longus who just did her super with Fang
hits all characters so she can snipe out
back row characters cool Winchester's
super is mind sniper what she does is
she automatically targets any character
casting and it can cancel out their
cancel out their spell but you have to
time that right so like if someone no
one's using a spell you kind of waste it
yeah kind of like that so it's it's it's
is a very timing focused game it's like
super super lightning fastpac yeah
that's it's almost like a rhythm I feel
like you get into when you start to like
learn it right that's that's exactly
what we're going for it's a little bit
Rhythm combat um and each battle gets a
little fiercer now we have uh we have
one of these Wolves and the wolves are
some of our fastest enemies cuz these
guys can do a three hit combo on you
like that but you can if you perfect
block right before right when they
attack you you can stagger them and when
they're staggered to they also take
double damage for a little bit of time
about 5 Seconds
okay so right after this we're going to
be making one of those choices I was
talking about uh when you make a choice
there'll be three different card options
are come on screen they'll ask you a
choice for the story you know how do you
want to react to the situation in
addition to that there'll be three
different Buffs that you can pick from
these Buffs will help you only
throughout the level but sometimes you
might need these like one of these Buffs
might be to revive a fallowing character
or you know maybe a buff will allow you
to shoot Fireballs instead of regular
bullets but those Buffs are also TI of
the story so if you take a buff that you
know revives a character you might do
something terrible for your kingdom but
depends on what you feel like you want
to
do yeah so what's what's the overarching
objective like in the end game uh the
overarching objective for the princess
is to get back to the kingdom to claim
claim the throne in her name okay see on
play on the games come up for both
PlayStation 4 and Playstation vaa the VA
vers is actually a different story play
as her antagonist the legate who also
try's try to take theone from her so
they're both racing back to the K to try
to claim uh to claim the throne
okay all right yeah we got through it
I'm trying to keep up I'm not even one
so right now there barbarians are
Marching to this remote Village what do
you want to do do you want to defend the
town or do you want to give this town to
these barbarians so they they become
allies Barbarian allies pleas Barbarian
okay manipulate it is so if we survive
this level we'll see how this uh
decision will impact the world Okay cool
so it's your decisions have consequences
yeah
yeah what are these meters I'm seeing
around the individual buttons oh yeah
that's a great question so each me each
uh White node there is one attack okay
so you can store up to three attacks for
characters and if you perfect blocking
attack you actually all characters
recover one bar immediately so you can
count really Qui points almost yeah
there are
there are they are action points cool
looks like you just BL all okay yeah
that that attack brong horns is a a
Malay attack that also recovers life for
the car for the attacker so that's a a
good
block yeah these goblins are vious also
this is not a like this is not a level
at the beginning of the game this like a
mid game level I was going to say I hope
this isn't like the tutorial screwed we
I kind of felt that we show the tutorial
level might be a little too slow so we
just kind of jumped right into the
middle of the game here
okay do you have a favorite character to
use uh my favorite character is actually
Winchester okay um mainly because like
she's really good at at giving debuffs
to characters like so if you cancel if
you if you uh attack with one character
and you switch n just like that there's
a blue ore around them that's called
like that's called link attack so when
you cancel attack you do an alternate
attack Winchester's alterate attack she
shoots a bullet that reduces the enemy's
attack power by 50% okay so I think
that's really handy zukar when you do
his link attack he dashes forth his
shield and can Smite an enemy so he'll
attack and defend
simultaneously okay
Sandra's nice you got we almost got this
guy
down
[Music]
nice yeah it is uh I'm actually glad
that my one of my good friends is
helping me show this game cuz I I could
not uh play and talk at the same
time
I can barely talk and watch at the same
time yeah it's I mean we want it to make
this game really intense and like we
want you to feel stressed down in the
best possible way when you're playing
this up in Triangle to
revive
so and uh our voice actor who plays
Princess win she's actually in a Persona
5 oh cool yeah she she's did a really
great job she helped us get all the
voice actors uh she's had a busy year
very busy year it's a a great year for
her yeah blocking is very very important
this game so if you block right before
the wmer attacks you you can stagger him
and he'll fall to the ground that'll
give you like you know maybe about one
and a half seconds where you can pound
on him okay see Winchester's down yeah
but it's a duel now it's a one-on-one oh
man we we want this game to have uh some
pretty crazy comebacks and actually if
you lose all of your characters you
still have one more Super comeback
princess to se at that point will go
into desperation mode it's a trance
where if you mash triangle you'll
recover your magic you mash fast enough
you might be able to recover enough
magic to fire to shoot like an attack
spell to finish enemy off or revive a
character like oh man oh so close but we
we've had some really crazy comebacks
with that uh let's should we retry try
the Boss B yeah yeah unless you beat
that wyvern yeah we've had some crazy
comebacks where uh we' had someone with
no people left have come back and uh
beat a boss okay and that that's
something that like when I was
programming in um I was watching people
when they play the game and they got
really close I wanted to give people
like another chance to to come
back yeah if you're just joining the
stream late uh you're confused by the
insanity unfolding on screen this is
Fallen Legion it's a RPG PS4 V and vaa
yeah right now it's just PS4 and vaa um
you know we're a small team of eight
that are making this so two platforms is
PL especially because the VA versions a
completely different game completely
different bosses story uh battles you
know it's it's more different than the
Pokemon X and
yess then yeah so it's this is all real
time controlling all four characters X
circle square buttons M to these
characters and then uh Healers triangle
in the back and you press you press the
L button to block and L2 and R2 rotate
your character
[Music]
War damn got Winchester back now yeah wi
Winchester Winchester is really good at
some C circumstances but not against uh
Malay heavy bosses like this wyvern uh
zacar and lence are really helpful
[Music]
here so on the PS v version you play as
I was saying you play as a legate who's
uh fighting to take the throne from The
Princess so in the PS4 version you'll
see him as an enemy while on the beta
version you that's who you're playing
you'll see princess Cil as the
[Music]
enemy Dam his wyvern gble he's he's he's
pretty tough uh he's he's not the
toughest boss but yeah he he can he can
be pretty pretty cruel uh may maybe I'll
I'll jump in and uh and give it a shot
all right is it right if I grab the
controller yeah sure just uh hand it
over to you from behind the scenes here
yeah all right so you said each of the
possible party members is based around
like an actual weapon yeah yeah so
there's six core party members here
they're each they're each based
on they're each based on a a
weapon
you seem like you know what you're doing
I assume you do I hope
[Music]
so the wyvern's just like wow this guy
got much better what
happened what's Sky splitter that I see
that's one that's a death one it's one
of the super moves at uu so the
character the fifth slot when the
glowing flame there will uh attack and
do a super move that bar will change
depending on how you the game too
okay so you might get different BFFs
like maybe the character in the third
slot will cast Shield magic or the
character in the fourth slot will have
be able to inflict poison when they
[Music]
attack Elia
BL
I think you got this I hope so let see
[Music]
dang
yeah
sand
[Music]
yeah there it is there we go what a way
to finish yeah so remember we chose to
manip manipulate The Barbarians into uh
helping into allying with us so um now
we're actually going to make that deal
and we're going to negotiate and talk
with the barbarians okay
[Music]
um
so these barbarians are planning to
attack this town area and you you could
have saved it but you know we chose to
give this town over to them
okay pretty cruel it was my it was my
idea choice but but you know you may
deal with them so you get an item for it
and uh you can when you play the game
you're going to have a lot of hard choic
to make that you're going to need to
make uh in about 5 Seconds cuz that's
how long you have to make them I saw the
meter taking down it's a really it's
really really lightning fast on that so
you know we want people to think fast go
with their gut instinct maybe they want
a buff maybe they want to go with the
story but the game will change depending
on so now if we go to this Village if we
go IA here we'll see that this Village
is overrun with barbarians before uh
these people here were kind of like on
the fence of they're going to support uh
princess's succession to the throne or
if they're going to do something else
okay but uh instead of helping the
legate or or helping you you've given
this town to them the barbarians and you
got an item for it which will what was
the item uh you got an it so the so the
the item is is one of the different
Buffs that you can get when you play
through level so the Buffs actually
change every time you play levels so
they randomize so that adds a new buff
to the pool so that buff uh gives
Winchester uh quadruple damage uh when
you fight uh Beast type monsters like a
wolf or or a Wyn or a wyvern which could
have been helpful you know earlier
yeah so you always have uh sorry what's
her name uh princess CIA
she's always in youry yeah she's always
she is the the human character so I'm
going to jump to one of the another one
of the hard levels here I'll pick a
different team of characters here we mol
here who's a really heavy here but slow
we have Paul in here who's uh who's an
Archer he's kind of a quick character
who Dell Dell is a range tank character
okay so who was the third one D L's okay
yeah she's kind of like a range tank
sweet you said that wyvern was an early
game Boss uh it was it was kind of like
a like a mid game Boss maybe like about
a third through the game
okay you got a few couple range
characters now yeah but I only have
Moler to to kind of absorb the damage
for them kind of soak up damage he's
he's slow he's a tanky character though
yeah he's he's tanky slow but hard
hitting it's a massive hammer
[Music]
do is this still a pretty early game
Mission or you said this is a little
harder this is a lot hard so so when I
made this demo that we're be showing at
the mix event we kind of jump through
levels a little bit here so at the end
here we have this we have a big boss
called Hydra it's like a multi-headed
boss can you just block every attack if
you time it right yeah you can there
there actually there are a few attacks
that we have that are unblockable spells
but you can cancel them out by hitting a
character enough ahead of time okay
[Music]
sand
coia's
blessing is that Cassandra's coil is
that some like a special attack too yeah
that's the princess's attack spell so
Cassandra is one of the goddesses in the
game so she's like invoking that goddess
power she shoots her shoot her magic
missiles
enemies look super different here too
yeah like barbarians
anymore yeah so these are some of the
soldiers that are uh that were once your
allies and that are not playing against
you
okay and that is that because of a
decision you made earlier on uh yeah I
baked that decision for this demo but
yeah something like that so now I can
pick here if for these choice I can
increase mol new strength or I can have
every time d nails attacks with with her
full bar uh she can recover a little bit
of HP for everybody okay so I'm gon to
go with that it's more defensive Choice
cool so now she has like a little bit of
little bit of a healing magic power
added to her regular attack how are you
blocking Oh by L1 here
[Music]
okayand
yeah these Shield units are kind of like
mold they're slow but then they hit you
it really hurts and they're also good at
defending other allies with them so they
have an ability call cover so if I
didn't kill that other sorcerer first he
would walk up and absorb damage for her
oh
gotcha how many characters are there
total that you can use that's a great
question now we have six core characters
that we're showing now
other things will happen to him
depending on the choices you make
okay all right so uh I'm just going to
go with the Buffs that are more
interesting so we pick Circle here even
though we exploited these these peasants
you know D now we shoot different
bullets so okay it's a catch 22 with
that but but now I can shoot these laser
beam bullets which which is pretty nice
but I have forsaken an entire Village to
get that ability yeah so it goes
[Music]
does that that just do poison damage as
Arrow yeah yeah so um aalen's link
attack when you switch between he he
shoots a poison arrow that can that hits
all
characters and M link attack he does
this Whirlwind he like spins around and
and uh pushes other enemies forward okay
this is one of the baby dragons here
from
[Music]
[Applause]
there alysia's
blessing sand
[Music]
coil
ouch oh man that's not good that is not
good oh you just revive him yeah revive
you can stalk your revive so I had my
revive right but two range characters
against against one dragon is not a good
situation
nice
so earlier in the story our princess AO
killed some of their allies so this
group is out to uh get
[Music]
[Applause]
revenge
cool have to unfortunately might have to
wrap it up soon all right get a maybe
maybe we can get hopefully if I'm fast
we can get teaser this Hydra here yeah
oh is that the that's the the Hydra the
final boss for this
area he's after these guys here let see
if I can speed this
up
nice those laser bullets seem to be
helping yeah I'm glad I took that
now is circle always kind of a malicious
decision uh not always not always it's
sometimes it's actually really more of
experimental so I guess we'll have to
leave this guy for everyone else to play
later on when Fallen Legion comes out
later this year cool yeah so this is
Fallen Legion it's a uh RPG with u real
time combat pretty intense crazy from
what I've seen doesn't look like I'll be
good at it anytime soon but I definitely
want to play it y thanks so much for
having than so much for coming on and uh
if you're just joining us we are here uh
on Gam YouTube twitch we are doing our
Indie mix live stream for GDC 2017 we
have a lot of developers in town we're
moving on to our final game for the day
we have another 20 minutes uh with Steve
Gainer from FBR company um going to be
showing us Tacoma uh followup to their
debut title gone home Steve how's it
going hey good to see you man you too
thanks having me on cool yeah we're uh
be playing Tacoma on PS4 it looks like
is that what I'm seeing or no that was
Fallen Legion we're still we Xbox
controller down here though yeah it's be
on Xbox One and PC later this year cool
yeah um yeah there's been some really
awesome looking stuff on the stream so
far yeah I know Fallen Le that game look
crazy yeah yeah we showed uh yanan came
on used to be at FL bre company to show
where the water tastes like wine yeah uh
would you rather play do you want me to
play you want to play and talk about it
like honestly so um if you're at GDC um
Tacoma is playable at the day of the
devs Showcase um if you're not at GDC um
you can check it out here on the stream
I figure um I don't know why don't you
play it and I'll just uh you know I can
commentate a little bit or we can just
kind of discuss I'm also happy to just
have you play and kind of have a a quiet
stream unless there's anything you want
to ask about it so uh yeah well I mean
it's totally up to you would you rather
just show off well so the the pitch for
Tacoma before we jump right in is um
Tacoma is a story exploration game that
takes place on a space station in the
year 2088 so you as a contractor have
been sent here by the company that owns
the station to retrieve the AI um and
and return it to them and while you're
on the station you encounter basically
digital Echoes of what happened to the
crew before you arrive okay so the
beginning of this demo is kind of right
after the intro as you're really just
getting your first steps into the
station itself okay cool yeah so I'll
probably just shut up unless I mean we
have the YouTube and twitch chats up if
people have questions about uh Tacoma
then feel free to throw them our way
we'll bring it up try to keep an eye on
that
[Music]
too your body positional data has been
registered with Tacoma's AR
Network please sign in to confirm your
[Music]
identity thank you welcome aboard so
yeah Tacoma Station is kind of all about
this augmented reality overlay on the
world you're seeing that includes Amy
using the interface to text and interact
with the world um it also be a lot of
how you
uncover the
story you kind of see we're in this Cal
Force 2001 Style Space Station so in the
center of the station you're floating
fully in zero gravity so you have you
know the ability to to move through this
space um without being constrained by
gravity but then as you proceed down the
arms of the station to the habitation
sections you'll really feel the
difference of you know you're in full
gravity where people kind of spend their
day-to-day lives
cool
hold on one second one second okay um so
yeah check out your um AR desktop before
you proceed to Personnel that's see
other sorry it's good um so part of what
AR is about is that it's sort of the
interface for people's lives in um our
version of 2088 so at any point the the
characters and Amy who you're playing as
um can open up sort of this personal
interface in their Vision okay um and so
you know go ahead and kind of explore
your um your desktop okay um you know we
have like more information about the
mission and the the crew of The Station
um and also on the other side of of her
interface over on the left side of the
the Horseshoe um there's a you you
receive messages from your handlers yeah
as you're
going um there's a you know map of the
station and everything but this is kind
of here um to ground you
within how the how the crew um kind of
lives their lives um and this is how
they're exchanging information all
throughout their their day to-day cool
back out of this now yeah sure cool then
we're going to Personnel looks like
sound first one go on into the
observation
down so these are kind of the
recoverable bits of data that are left
over um when you so you really miss it
huh well it just seems like it'd be
strange being back on Earth already
after only a year up here really after
all I've had to hear from you about the
conditions VT has us working under yeah
but there's that and and then there's
this yeah I I'll miss it that's you're
kind of you know you're experiencing
these um these moments you know that
that happened before you arrived and are
kind of placing yourself within them um
and so you know in a in a scene like
this is just sort of a a fragment of
something that that happened to the crew
and what they're talking about maybe do
some context for for what else you're
going to be finding and also it you know
sort of maybe leads you you follow and
you're like oh okay I'm I'm kind of
following in their footsteps it kind of
um is one way of reacting to the
environment then once we get down into
the Personnel Wing um we kind of add a
layer of complexity onto that okay so
yeah awesome and then you can just
restart want to or just go right
yeah how cool is that just uh traveling
zero g right so you know the the um the
idea of a centrifugal force station is
that you know the the habitable wings
are spinning and so that causes
artificial gravity on the on the far
side and so fictionally as you're moving
down this arm you know Amy is getting
heavier right and so by the time that
you get to the bottom you're in um full
Earth gravity and you kind of totally
changed your um your method of of
traversal once you're down
okay and so like those uh the AR
characters that we're seeing the kind of
like AR ghost of those people will those
be recurring characters or will I just
see a bunch of different ones throughout
the station so we are introducing you to
a consistent set of characters through
the thing so the game is really about
building your understanding and your
relationship with the characters that
that we first saw there and that's going
to continue to to kind of build as we go
okay so Amy's you know job is to
retrieve the ai ai data from each of the
wings of the station which is what
you're doing here um you're you're
starting basically this um transfer
process um but then while that's ongoing
you're free to explore the different
parts of the station and dig into more
of what happened um to the crew and and
really what your real motivation is for
being here got um so yeah we should
probably go over to the the admin Wing
where you were headed before when you
plug one of those in it activates the AR
interface in the in that part of the
station and then you can interact with
things like doors and and uh and so
forth how much effort went into like
trying to make the Sci-Fi aspects of the
space station uh
like believe or maybe not believable but
like accurate I mean obviously it's
fictional yeah right well those two
things I think um it's interesting
because they do kind of go hand inand
but also they aren't totally um believe
they AR the same thing right because
something that is something can be
believable without being totally
scientifically accurate I think that our
our our intent is to walk that line and
say the stuff that that you know could
exist in the current day the stuff about
just like
how you know space travel and and
gravity and planetary orbits and stuff
work we're trying to do as much as we
can to make that stuff work how it how
it would you know like say okay this is
real technology that they might the the
way that they might build a long-term
habitation station this is like where
they might put the station you know that
kind of stuff um but then within that we
have the the other side of it which is
you know I think that it's totally um
plausible to think that in the future um
our lives may be very heavily kind of
like influenced by this kind of overlay
this idea there's always digital
information just kind of like in the
world in your view at any time but since
it's speculative fiction we're able to
kind of take our vision of that and say
you know how might that work what what
might our version of that be and with a
scene like this saying if there's sort
of um um like surveillance technology on
the on the station the company is is
tracking the um the crew all the time
then maybe there's this digital record
of what happened
anding back through that is I guess an
extrapolation of you know what might be
as opposed to like this is accurate this
is what's actually going to happen but
yeah at this point you've seen kind of
an exchange between um Nat and BT so hit
X to pause so at this point we've sort
of seen parallel threads happening at
once like you hung out at the dining
table and you saw that Andrew and Clive
came in from the kitchen and maybe you
saw that Sarah was down playing pool and
so a big part of the game is saying
there're these um um kind of webs of
events that are happening in a location
and because it's digital information you
have kind of like you know VCR controls
to not just move through space and find
objects but to move through the timeline
of what happened and put yourself inside
of it so you know I would say um
whatever other aspect of this scene that
you think you might want to explore kind
of what was happening at the same time
um pull back and and follow somebody
else in the scene okay and she's Sarah's
the one that was in that zero g earlier
right
exactly
what you're looking for no I just
imagine well I guess I just mean someone
I can talk to someone who makes me laugh
don't you so Odin the station AI who
you're here to bring back is also a
character in the story and so I think
part of what you're discovering
especially early on is what kind of
entity what kind of Consciousness he is
what kind of relationship the crew has
to him and so you know you can see in
this scene that some of the
crew relate to him very much person you
know and are kind of building a
relationship um with him like anybody
else but how different crew members kind
of conceive of what Odin is and what
they think of him is is part of I think
hopefully what's part of the interesting
Dynamic of this this whole group of
people if you want to play pool or darts
or anything yes we are each uniquely
evolved individualized entities yes
individuals do you get along with other
AIS I have never encountered another AI
what is that is that what like Odin
would have looked like at the time it
was happening or is that just an AR
manifestation of what he looks like so
it's um basically our our thinking is um
that Odin is not technically in any kind
of like single physical location right
umow but while uh he was uh you know
while these events were ongoing um
organizations that share you a the so
you might want to pause it while she
heads upstairs sorry um while these
events are ongoing while the characters
are interacting with him there's this um
kind of I think human need to have some
manifestation of him something to focus
on so our idea is that these recordings
are capturing everything that was
happening in AR um during these moments
and that includes where any individual
kind of like instance of Odin was being
placed so that the the you know crew
members have something to kind of make
eye contact with as it were um but you
know practically speaking he's kind of
everywhere all at once and you know if
you want to go up to the to the kitchen
maybe um you'll find that you know as
you're so the the game is really about
putting these pieces of the the the
timeline together into a hole so yeah up
around to the left um and maybe you know
pull the timeline back and as you're
kind of adding up this stuff and and
um and kind of putting the pieces
together of what was happening when
you'll find that you know Odin can
actually be in multiple places at the
same time talking to multiple people um
and it's really just about what their
individual um inter like you know uh uh
experience of him is in a lot of ways oh
he's in here too yeah cool yeah and
someone in the chat is asking I don't
know if
like probably can't talk about this but
I mean like with all the AR it begs the
question did do you guys have ideas to
bring this to like VR at all I mean we
we are currently totally focused on the
uh whatever the traditional formats PC
and Xbox but you know I am encouraged by
seeing advances that have happened in
just like how games like this are being
translated into VR recently like I I was
I it was really interesting to see how
positively people responded to like
Resident Evil 7 in VR and being like
this game works great in VR this is a
full first person game and it actually
like is really you know solid as an
experience um so you know I think
there's possibilities for that kind of
stuff but it would is is certainly not
going to be our uh our first uh line of
defense sure yeah yeah um so something
that might be interesting is yeah if you
want to follow around Eevee in there
um yeah go for me I am prepared okay so
something else on top of just like
following the characters and listening
to them is that anytime that they were
using their AR desktop um during one of
these scenes that's captured as well so
you can recover the data that that she
was looking at on her desktop and so
that's information um that only she had
at the time um and so you know while
you're you're following the characters
listening to the scenes um you're you're
kind of able to also see what they were
seeing um and it's it's sort of another
way to build context for the events of
the story as they were happening in the
timeline
[Music]
gotcha Eevee is the what's her job on
the station uh I think we actually put
that down in the bottom middle yeah so
she's she's the station admin so she's
kind of the the boss captain of the ship
if if it were a ship
yeah well this be translatable no so as
you can see like a lot of the the data
has been lost so you know I think that
you know what gone home was about um
what a lot of the stuff that we've
worked on um even going back to manous
den was about is the idea of there being
gaps in the narrative sure right and
there only being so much that you
actually have access to and so in terms
of Tacoma part of our our challenge was
fac If It's All Digital if we can't just
say well there's one Post-It note that's
been left here you know so that's an
isolated thing um how do we make it so
you don't just have like infinite access
to all the information and so Amy being
here to recover the AI after there was
some sort of incident um gave us the
ability to say okay so a bunch of the
data on the station has been lost and
you can only have access to the stuff
that is like recoverable by your system
um and so
as you go through you're finding the
bits and pieces of what's left over but
it's sort of the uh the interpretive job
of the player to to make the connections
between okay yeah
cool is that's something I'd find in her
logs
well
almost maybe uh follow her more through
this through this scene a little bit is
it 0451 no it isn't all right I I will
guarantee youal stasis cry beds until
she can we're about to Cut the Cake ah
right um be right there Odin we'll get
back to this after the party okay of
course
up
oh I think I saw it yeah so that's you
know so that's some of the stuff that
we're that we're kind of trying to make
the player conversent with the AR and
with the with how the crew use the
interface as well as how you do okay um
to kind of have a yeah sometimes stuff
like unlocking a a a a key code door
right but um sometimes it's giving you
an idea of
sure what they were experiencing before
you arrived cool so sometimes it's
practical sometimes it's just like you
know okay what's she reacting to and now
you can interact with the AR to to
discover you know what her um her
experience was yeah it's interesting it
seems like the next step in that you
know like like you said gone home is
maybe more traditional uh you know like
notes being left around audio logs kind
of in that kind of a contextual story
Stelling environmental storytelling but
this seems like the next evolution of
that kind of more futuristic obviously
but also like this seeing her put that
code in it actually affects how I play
it right well and you know we we hope
that we hope that's true I mean what we
wanted to do was to make sure that we
weren't you know repeating ourselves
like you know I think that that gone
home is the kind of game that you could
totally make more gone home with a
different place and a different story
and a different set of things that
you're finding I think that could be a
totally good game but as far as what our
Ambitions were we wanted to say how can
we take that as a Baseline
and like you're saying take the next
step towards how you're directly
involved with the events as they're
happening how you have kind of an
interactive dialogue with the story
without it being you know branching
Choice without it being about you know
something like a a Telltale Game or or
something like that but more of just you
have uh an expanded interactive role
within how you're finding all the events
of of what happened okay it's like
something went wrong here yeah yeah so
this is kind of the the motivating
action at the end of this scene is
what's going to set up the rest of the
game there just the the the first hint
of what the crew has had to dealt with
um before you arrive there's like traces
of like Minority Report in it right is
that what I'm thinking of when you just
re like recreating the scene yeah for
sure I mean and I I'll take that
comparison because I think most people
um with Minority Report think of the
whole like you know swooping around
moving the and stuff um in our universe
um AR is kind of a it's a direct um
communication between the users sensory
cortex and the interface so it's kind of
tracking your attention basically you're
not doing anything with your hands
except like when she was doing text
entry sure um but the the aspect of
Minority Report that I think is
interesting here is that idea of being
able to reconstruct events from multiple
angles replay them and kind of see them
in a fuller way than um you could just
from a single Viewpoint cool
okay you said that's like a so
obsolescence day what is I think they
mentioned it before I think but I kind
of well something that we found was
really interesting about um you know
groups of people who work on isolated um
uh uh facilities like Arctic bases um
for instance um is that there's a lot of
coping mechanisms basically have to deal
with the fact that every day is kind of
the same right there's no there's no
night and day when you're when you're on
the South Pole or you know in space you
you are in this sort of static
environment and so what happens a lot is
people kind of make up excuses for
having celebrations for like creating
events so they can have jobs so they can
say we're all building towards this one
big thing that we're going to do
together and it helps them Mark time and
kind of like structure um their stay and
so in this case obsolescence day um kind
of deeper within the story is about um
how human Crews on uh orbital stations
were meant to be made obsolete a long
time ago but there are still humans out
there in space and so the people that
are working there kind of celebrate this
day every year about their they're still
being Crews like them cool um out in
orbit it's cool so that was the end of
that scene it's probably a good work
heading this way next yeah okay yeah I
mean the our our demo um will wrap up
when you're in this this bunk so that'll
probably be a great place to to put a
cap on it but um you know the part of
the experience aside from the core plot
and kind of the the events as they
happen is like gone home having access
to these characters personal space and
evidence of who they are as individuals
um and so there are some of these um AR
fragments that are basically like
partially corrupted moments um that that
you can recover um that generally tend
to be more of small moments um about who
these these people are and kind of more
of an insight into what they do when um
when they're not in kind of a big group
setting cool um and so you know in a in
a scene like this um we just kind of get
to be with Eevee for a few minutes while
she's playing guitar and singing and um
get an idea of what she's like um in her
personal space cool if that's all there
is is my friend and something that you
know I think is interesting is if you
look like out the skylights anywhere
that you are you can always kind of see
where you are in the station so that
that sense of being able to look out in
space and see the structure of this this
place that you're just like a very small
part of it
cool it's nice
awesome feel like we'll get to know the
station pretty pretty well yeah
really
yeah thank you for for guiding us
through our our little glimpse of Tacoma
Mike I appreciate it so much Steve uh so
just this year right now is the yeah
window yeah we're we're aiming for
middle of this year cool yeah awesome so
that Steve Gainer from Full company
known for their debut title gone home
from
2013 uh Tacoma is coming out sometime
2017 uh team has grown a little bit few
people you're in there yeah yeah we're
um we're eight people now so we doubled
in size Goa yeah huge huge theme
tackling Tacoma but uh yeah uh just like
everybody else we brought on today uh be
at the Indie mix event tonight if you
happen to be in San Francisco otherwise
we'll I'm sure we'll have more Tacoma
coverage throughout the week uh
throughout the year you know leading up
to whenever it releases and everything
and we're looking forward to it thanks
so much Steve yeah thank you again for
having me on yeah you around this week
all right cheers cool uh for those
joining uh YouTube Gamespot or twitch we
are here with the Indie mix stream uh
that was the last game we were showing
that was Tacoma we showed Fallen Legion
we showed punch planet we showed sunnd
we showed where the water tastes like
wine and we showed Beacon uh so now we
have uh we're going to bring on some of
the guys from Indie miix to kind of wrap
things up uh come on down now I believe
it's Justin we're going to be talking to
here uh recording a little yeah he's
recording showing us to wrap up the
stream Justin nice to meet you nice to
have you on what's up man cool how you
doing how's it going I'm good so uh tell
us about Indie miix tell us about GDC
what's going on this week GDC is crazy
if you guys don't know it's uh I'm a
game developer as well we actually came
with um Jason Muse because we're working
on our game Jay and Sil of Bob um so
this is like the the mecca of uh game
developers right now it's the biggest
you know um event in the world for game
developers so we're here to show a bunch
of to work with developers to uh share a
bunch of amazing games like really top
tier indie game developers um and we we
basically started this because we were
game developers ourselves and we were
having a hard time getting press and
media covered since we're the small guy
and we're we're just just like uh
everyone else who who's been on the
stream so far they are working really
really really hard on their games and
they don't have a lot of time to do a
lot of the press media you know Outreach
and and those type of things so we're
trying to help make that a little bit
easier and help awesome developers get
coverage and and stuff like that yeah
it's awesome we saw a bunch of cool
games today uh of all different types
and that's probably like some of the
coolest things coming out of these small
teams some of the are like games people
were like working on part-time
seems like full-fledged games in
themselves which they are but it's all
like you know free time like passion
projects almost yeah they look like
straight up like AAA games you know what
I mean like it's cool where the tools
have have gotten Indie developers yeah
to this you know to this point and um
Spencer has his his own website based on
you know Japanese games so it's cool to
see like how he took his love for that
type of art style like vanillaware and
brought it to his uh game development
Studio sure yeah we're lucky enough to
like you know have everybody in one spot
uh like I said if people are who are in
San Francisco whether they're going to
GC or not the Indie mix event is tonight
and then uh you know like throughout the
week obiously be they'll be on the show
floor I'm going to try to get over
tomorrow to yeah try to walk around find
up try all the games we didn't have on
today but yeah um had a lot of people
show up in the YouTube chat twitch chat
Gamespot chat it was uh people are
excited to see these games and uh had a
great time
yeah what's uh what was what's your
schedule like the rest of the week with
Indie mix stuff uh the schedule's pretty
crazy um cuz we have the mix tonight uh
and we're working with um some other
partners on some other showcases to help
other more visibility um and I also work
I don't know if I could say names or
whatever is that cool yeah go for it
yeah so I work with uh fig as well um
and they uh a crowdfunding for for video
game so I'm going to be talking to a lot
of developers to try to get you know
them funding um and then just you know
this is like where all my friends are at
right now so we're going to be meeting
talking about our games and then um you
know at GDC they have some pretty good
talks some of my friends are talking so
that should be cool yeah a lot of
interesting panels I'm gonna I don't
know if I'll have time to get to any of
them like obviously our news team's
going to be covering themy get the word
out on a gam spot of course uh any last
minute thoughts anything I didn't ask
you want to add in I just want to say
thank
for hosting these awesome developers you
guys picked some great game I mean all
the games are from the mix are great but
yeah no we wish we could have gotten
more you know just like time constraints
the week is crazy yeah but it's great to
to see them you know uh be able to come
up and and share their games and I hope
that everybody um is able to pick them
up when they come out absolutely yeah
and just support indie game developers
cuz you know we really work hard on our
craft and to make really good stuff for
us us but then also of course we want to
make everyone happy Awesome Justin
thanks so much for coming on to wrap
things up with me appreciate it thanks
man uh yeah so like for those who joined
uh thanks so much for joining us on
YouTube on Twitch on Gamespot we had an
awesome time playing six of these games
played fall Legion Tacoma where the
water tastes like wine Beacon sundered
and the first one punch Planet had a
bunch of awesome pretty diverse games I
don't think we really kind of genre
jumped all day which is nice awesome so
uh yeah it's been interesting all day
but again everybody thanks so much for
joining we'll have coverage for gdt 2017
out of San Francisco the whole week here
at Gamespot got a really cool we got a
prey stream with RF col anonio from
Arcane Studios on Wednesday uh we got a
bunch of people coming in come back
11:00 a.m. Pacific on Wednesday for the
lobby our live show um I know I'm sure
we got a bunch of other games I'm
forgetting it's a crazy week but again
thanks so much for joining us and we'll
see you
[Music]
later